welcome back to me rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in one division gave us its first
official teaser as part of the Marvel
Disney Plus Super Bowl spot alongside
another upcoming series like come winter
soldier and Loki but damn one division
is the most vibrant and most worthy of
saying I understood that reference by
the looks of things the Avenger with
powers so forgettable even her accent
has forgotten is getting a makeover to
restore the character to her amazing
reality swapping abilities from the
comics I'm gonna decode this footage and
piece together how I think this bonkers
series will play out when it comes out
later this year
now I covered the Falcon Winter Soldier
footage in another video go check that
out and I will be covering Loki in a
different video coming very soon spoiler
warning in case my Wanda bitchin
predictions into being too accurate and
ruin your life let's roll the clip we
just got hit with a rapid-fire super cut
of Wanda Maximoff envisioned and a
handful of sitcom realities varying by
the amount of Technicolor hairspray and
waist height and there was also this
clip from the end of the trailer ok
let's start by breaking down all of the
Wanda visions sitcom references here
there's one black and white sitcom
reality apparently based on classic 50s
sitcoms like I Love Lucy and The
Honeymooners
I'm gonna guess I Love Lucy because I
expect vision will be less likely to
threaten spousal abuse then again there
was that time he wouldn't let her leave
the kitchen
then there's the quick shot of Wanda in
the characters classic Scarlet Witch
comic costume with a red cape and
headpiece but notice they include the
ribbon that fastens the cape on and the
headpiece is clearly cardboard so this
is obviously meant to be a costume in
context here like one a sitcom character
would wear on a Halloween episode so I'm
wondering if this reality could be like
the 60s sitcom bewitched with Scarlet
Witch as the enchanting witch that the
man comes home to there are also shots
of Wanda in 70s attire in hair similar
to Marcia Brady from The Brady Bunch
there's the same exact kind of stares at
the Brady Bunch set had it's also worth
noting that Wanda is pregnant in this
shot and that brings us to the brief
shot of Wanda and vision in an 80s
sitcom their clothes and house evokes
shows like full house
step by step family ties and now the
babies she was pregnant with are born
because notice they're standing in front
of two cribs with the babies adorably
spitting out their pacifier
and to me this at least partly has to be
an in-joke by Elizabeth Olsen to her
older twin sisters who got their start
as the twin babies on Full House but yes
there is a deeper story to Wanda's kids
I'll get to that a bit but next there's
a shot showing Wanda in plaid no girls
big hair in front of a kitchen fridge
covered in children's art one has a
letter B which I believe could be for
Billy Kaplan aka the marvel mutant
Wiccan who is kind of Wanda's kid along
with his twin brother speed
Tommy Shepard Wanda definitely looks to
be in mom mode here perhaps from a 90s
sitcom showing middle class families
like Roseanne married with children and
lastly there's a shot of I Love Lucy
Wanda on a 50s TV set which gets
switched off as present-day Wanda
struggles to keep her balance completely
thrown by the fact that she is trapped
in this black-and-white Pleasantville
type reality now based on all of these
clues I think we've pretty decent idea
of what this could look like in terms of
episodes but before I get to that like
Wanda Maximoff I often find myself
confused by my own clothing which
sometimes you may have noticed switches
abruptly amid video so in an attempt to
expand my wardrobe options I have well
gotten frustrated shopping online
because I always find out about those
coupon codes right after I buy something
like I could use that well honey
simplifies online shopping with coupon
codes and thanks to honey by the way for
sponsoring this breakdown honey is the
free online shopping tool that
automatically finds promo codes and
applies them to your cart and it only
takes two clicks to install when you
check out this little box drops down and
all you have to do is click apply
coupons and you wait a few seconds for
it to scan all the Brembo codes from
across the internet and then watch the
prices drop recently I was shopping
online for some headphone adapters and
honey found a 52 percent off coupon save
me 10 bucks so then I was about to pay
full price for which makes me feel smart
and savvy like those people who do their
taxes on time and can speak French new
rock stars fans that have downloaded
honey in the past using our promo code
have already saved themselves over two
hundred thousand dollars collectively
you're welcome and you thought I was
only helping you win nerdy arguments
with your friends not having honey is
literally passing up free money folks
it's free to use and installs in just
two clicks so get honey for free at join
honeycomb slash new rock stars that's
join honey calm slash new rock stars
okay so here's my theory for this
of Wanda vision Wanda Maximoff Scarlet
Witch is known for her reality altering
powers which she is best known for from
the House of M conic Series in that
storyline Wanda loses her mind and
chaotically resets reality over and over
again swapping in and out of alternate
universes some of which she has two
mutant children and later on in the
Marvel comics those two kids were
revealed as Wiccan and speed long-lost
twin brothers they initially vanished
from existence but then like their souls
were being inserted into new bodies some
people think and because comics anyway I
think one division is adapting house of
M with one a Maximoff grieving over
visions death in the war against Thanos
and that grief manifesting and Towanda
living her dream family life with vision
through various hypothetical sitcom
realities this season could look like
shows like mr. robot or Legion which
featured mentally unhinged heroes
bending genre as they slip in and out of
fantasy scenarios Wanda's sitcom life
with vision appears to progress through
the decades newlyweds and I Love Lucy
married life and bewitched early
pregnancy and the Brady Bunch
new parents and full house and raising
young kids and teenagers and Roseanne
perhaps this will open with Wanda
transporting her consciousness into
visions Android corpse and like an
attempt to resurrect him but then what
we see is a grieving Wanda's
consciousness navigating the
complexities of visions mind which
remember is robotic and composed of data
inputs inputs like twentieth-century
television so her arrival in this
bizarre reality would begin with Wanda
and her normal clothes but in color
landing in a black and white universe
because remember when vision died he D
saturated into monochrome so in her
attempt to revive him Wanda gradually
trying to bring more and more color into
his soul and by the intimate we may not
get vision back but perhaps the result
of Wanda's reality bending journey could
be a manifestation of twins Wiccan in
speed officially introducing mutants to
the MCU paving a path to MCU x-men
finally a number of MCU co-stars have
been confirmed for this series kat
dennings is returning from the Ford
movies as Darcy Lewis to Anna Paris is
playing an adult version of Monica
Rambeau Randall parks coming back as
agent Wu from ant-man in the wasp and
Catherine is
the MCU as an unnamed nosy neighbor they
could imagine each of these characters
populating a different sitcom reality
like maybe Katherine odd could be a
Wilson rank fence Kevin Feige is also
internet a cameo from Sparky the dog
from the Tom King vision comics which
reimagined vision as a fifties husband
and father similar to how he appears to
be depicted in this black-and-white
reality and with all this reality
swapping it is totally possible that one
of Wanda's dream realities could feature
her brother Quicksilver still alive why
am big and he would be crashing at her
place in the full house reality you know
since Danny Tanner got help raising his
girls with his wife's brother and also
with his best friend a failed comedian
now look when these Marvel trailers
dropped during the Superbowl the first
thing I did was jump on new rockstars
official discord to chat with our inner
circle nerds lately it's been really my
go-to place for theories and hot takes
and stuff that's just like too out there
too real for the videos here on YouTube
for exclusive access to our new rock
stars discord please consider becoming a
patron of new rock stars today at
patreon.com slash new rock stars which
of Wanda's alternate sitcom realities
are you most excited for comment on
below with your thoughts and again be
sure to check out my breakdown with
falcon Winter Soldier footage and stay
tuned for an upcoming explanation of the
Loki footage follow me at ei vas follow
new rock stars on social media and
subscribe to new rock stars for all of
our Marvel breakdowns thanks for
watching bye
[Music]